- michael d'efforts je vais raconter une
petite histoire j'en parle de qu'est ce
qu'on fait je quand même relativement
jeune j'ai pas 25 ans d'expérience mais
je veux partager notre humble expérience
en tant qu'organisation qui s'appelle
tribu expérientiel tribu qu'est ce qu'on
fait on prend quelque chose qui t'a
c'est une niche et les sports extrêmes
puis on les rend accessibles à la masse
comment on fait ça on sert de
l'adrénaline nos sports extrêmes
vous allez comprendre comment et puis je
vais montrer des exemples je veux
montrer aussi d où ces partis
et puis vous allez voir je parle assez
vite donc n'hésitez pas à lever la main
ou à venir me voir après pour en savoir
plus sans plus attendre quelques images
pour ceux qui sont en arrière vous
verrez peut-être pas j'ai mis mes
meilleurs shot numéro images de deux
mois qui fait de l'escaladé ou moins qui
a c'est de faire du wakesurf avec la
corne
quand je dis bien essayer parce que
c'est vraiment difficile je sais depuis
quelques années d'enfer mais bref je
montais image là avec un peu une
conscientisation que j'ai eu dans les
dernières années j'ai un petit village
qui s'appelle saint romain dans le coin
de lac-mégantic est un village de 700
habitants chercher moi pourquoi ma mère
avait choisi la maison dans le fond
durant de sept villages là à trois
heures de montréal il y avait un seul
voisin qui avait une ferme qu'un autre
voisin qui étaient des amis qui
habitaient à peu près un kilomètre plus
loin un très grand terrain de jeu à mon
travail en marketing à montréal et puis
pendant toute la semaine moi et mon
frère on avait la maison et le grand
terrain à nous tous seuls imaginer ce
que ça fait déjà un à cet âge là à
l'école secondaire tous nos amis ont été
malades chez nous la première fois à
boire de tourner à dacca à calais ça on
avait une rampe de skateboard une
trampoline un cap je pense c'est une
première époque où j'ai réussi à
comprendre que mon talent de rassembleur
prenait tout son sens bien ça pour des
parties recommencent ans mais vous allez
comprendre la suite c'est vraiment le
goût de l'adrénaline qui me cherchait à
créer ces expériences là avec mes amis
comme cobayes au début puis
éventuellement avec des grandes
entreprises par la suite
plus loin dans le temps j'habitais à
sherbrooke rejetée suivant ma gang en
gestion de commerces ont
allez dans la formation pour suivre un
peu comme tout le monde c'est pourquoi
je fais ça mais récemment jailli à
l'unisson dans l'est du dragon et puis
ça a très bien fonctionné j'ai eu trois
investisseurs qui ont embarqué
et puis tout a commencé par un sous un
seul challenge qui était la mare à ma
blonde qui m'a dit je te mets au défi
d'appliquer à l'émission dans l'es10
dragon j'ai appliqué j'étais sélectionné
j'ai passé les auditions puis bref une
belle histoire de succès je dis pas ça
pour me vanter je dise ça pour vous
donner un peu une idée que on peut
partir de très loin et puis
éventuellement créer des grandes choses
mais tout un concept donner des choses
ni chez les rendent accessibles à la
masse mon parcours est ma première
entreprise mon premier quart et de
saboter une marque de skateboard reaper
skate board cité quoi c'était une bande
l'ont prendront part du parti dans le
fond durant éventuellement une dizaine
de gros con con commandité j'avais une
marque de planche à roulettes et puis on
allait à travers l'europe et puis à
travers le canada pour vendre ses
planches là dans un réseau de 60
magasins de 60 magasins spécialisés
pardon je me suis rendu compte que
j'adorais le côté rassembleur le côté
tourné comme andy d'athlètes creaceed
création de contenu mais j'aimais
vraiment pas ma job de bureau qui était
qui ressemblait un vide cubicule avec
les cloisons grise moi j'étais un gars
qui auraient besoin de carburant j'ai
besoin d'adrénaline pour aller plus loin
donc dans ce timing est arrivé à là on
est rendu à montréal j'ai déménagé à
montréal après midi à sherbrooke
et puis dans un appartement je peux se
connaissaient de quartier heureusement
pas très loin un maçon 1re avenue
un outil très résidentiel on a justement
créé une compétition de snowboard
urbaine
je montre un extrait assez rapidement à
l'époque l'entreprise existe des banques
[Musique]
mon frère il mêle petit événement ils
ont peut-être au cola qui se sont dits
avec une idée un peu saugrenue va faire
une compétition de snowboard à montréal
dans nos appartements donc aller
chercher de la neige d'arena constitue
un obstacle mais fait déjà le tour était
joué
aussi loin spa 12 places les médias sont
débarqués était sur le toit en train de
filmer capter le moment métaux mes
voisins à côté je les voyais sur leur
balcon avec la roue verre de vin après
d'âpres ici là l'événement
cinq ans plus tard je me rends compte
que c'étaient mes clients tourisme
montréal qui étaient les voisins
l'époque les dix ans c'est toi qui
faisait la compétition de snowboard en
tout cas de renvoyer un peu les gens ont
un grand appartement les gens peuvent
être partout en arrière rien
d'impressionnant on s'entend mais le
lendemain matin je me suis réveillé avec
la piqûre pour l'événementiel puis
encore une fois une amie de l'époque m'a
dit je te mets au défi de le faire plus
grands histoires courtes
je me reconnais chez les gens à montréal
je commence à regarder en écho arrière
je commence à approcher les particuliers
en leur disant ce que vous me nourrir
une nourrice votre votre cour arrière
fond une compétition
imaginez leur réaction et mongi dit je
pense que tu as plus de chances à leurs
intérêts privés
on a éventuellement concours de
circonstance établi l'événement au
centre-ville de montréal coin
sainte-catherine passant de 100
personnes à 800 personnes au
centre-ville
j'ai changé de job j'ai gagné le
concours d'entrepreneuriat et puis par
la suite les événements quand même
gonflé de changer de partenaire est allé
dans une autre direction avec les
boutiques empire qui ont à déplacer
l'événement sur la rue saint-denis
connaissait besoin dans la section entre
sherbrooke et puis un fabricant taille
au pardon on avait 18 mille personnes en
décembre dernier cinq ans après la
première édition je m'entraîne postes
existants
ce que vous voyez en hausse et un la
plus gros événement de ce nom bol
urbains au canada ont été attribués le
producteur ça commence dans ma cour
arrière dangereusement 100% commandité
avec l'argent privé ya aucun argent
public est injectée là dedans
pourquoi ben je dis que c'est
intéressant de le mentionner c'est que
en fin du compte on offrait un événement
sport spectacle unique au canada aux
montréalais depuis quelques années
evènement changer non et a grandi avec
15000 en bourse ont fait un show télé
pour tva sports
on interdit l'année dernière avec des
commanditaires comme masse de monitoring
gifi dos les boutiques empire van buyten
oakley bref des grands noms de
l'industrie
et puis pourquoi je dis mentionne c'est
vraiment parce que au final on n'a pas
réinventé le sport tout le monde a déjà
vu que t'as dit snow ball à la télé est
à vous connaissez quelqu'un qui en fait
mais on n'en a pas pris ce concept de
prendre un événement si nombreux qu'on
verrait normalement en montagne on l'a
mis en plein coeur du quartier latin à
montréal sur la rue saint denis qui a
date dans tous les projets que je vous
montrais on réinvente pas la roue
on fait juste déplacé quelque chose de
niche et pour le rendre accessible à la
masse et puis ça s'est un peu sa propre
c'est un concept qui peut s'adapter pour
à peu près n'importe quoi selon moi que
ce soit un événement corporatif que ce
soit un événement de cinq personnes chez
vous à souper où que ce soit un
événement avec des milliers de personnes
en pleine rue que ce soit un party de
noël employés
si vous prenez quelque chose de niche et
que vous changé je suis un peu le
contexte
moi je pense qu'il est tout un message
qui peut être communiqué et puis c'est
ce qu'on appelle l'expérience yale
expérientiel c'est quoi pour nous notre
humble interprétation c'est vraiment ce
mix cette ligne invisible qui tissent
entre l'événement l'émotion et le
partage vous savez de nos jours ce
quelque chose d'intéressant on voit les
téléphones dans les arrête donc ce qui
est intéressant de noter si les gens ont
du plaisir il s'en rappellent qu'ils
sont capables de le partager
c'est mission accomplie c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'expérience hier rappelez vous
et je vous invite sur ce challenge là
mais 100 dans votre pays a besoin de me
répondre mais dans le dernier mois
combien de mamans combien de jours ont
été mémorable convient dans votre tête
vous fait dire je me rappelle des ex
nombre de jours qui ont été mémorable
s'il en est les plus que 5 vous êtes
vivait une ville
[Musique]
moi je me rappelle de 3,4 celui ci va
être un des moments mémorables
la réalité c'est que en vie nos vies
dans des routines nos journées se
répètent et se succèdent c'est normal
mais je pense qu'en tant que marque en
tant qu'entreprise en tant
qu'organisation il faut il faut vraiment
changer un peu comment on communique
avec les gens comme j'ai dit que ça soit
un souper à la maison ou éventuels merci
est un événement en soi où que ce soit
une grande célébration comme le 375e
dont on va donner le coup d'envoi les 7
8 et 13 14 15 janvier prochain avec
l'événement barbe ghazi le concept est
très simple on a tous moi je crois
beaucoup au concept participa
participants acteurs c'est-à-dire les
ménages entre les spectateurs soit
depuis que le snowboard donc les gens
ils viennent ils regardent derrière la
clôture puis c'est un beau show mais ils
vont pas aller prendre leur via vieilles
planches de neige poussiéreuse pour
s'essayer sur le parcours
c'est important d'avoir un aspect
participatif des spectateurs dans
l'événement qui on va proposer
c'est une grande course à obstacles
c'est l'événement qui lance le 3 7 5 qui
se déroule en janvier prochain au
quartier des spectacles qds en gros
c'est quoi imaginer que tout le monde
qui vient ou un bracelet rfid pour
collecter des points
et puis on fait une course à obstacles
de type où ils parlent tous avaient déjà
vu américaine ninja donc on s'élance
avec une course avec une corde à tarzan
tombe dans un bac de mousse faut ramper
dans un igloo traversant un pont de
corde face et d'esquiver un bar benghazi
qui veut dire barbe joli plongeon de
yéti un peu gros et éventuellement il
faut passer sur une poutre franchir une
forêt de sapins et monter un mur
d'escaladé taper le buzzer qui après
cinq minutes mais on va montrer la
sortie aux jeunes
s'ouvrir à tous c'est tout âge mais on
appelle la petite activité vraiment
ludique qui sont intéressants parce
noces kate est d'ailleurs de skateboard
des neiges
on a une compétition de bûcherons le
lancer du sapin
toutes les activités de compétition bras
de fer vous allez voir monsieur le maire
contre gilbert rozon probablement qu'ils
vont revenir faire c'est le 6 janvier
qui va gagner tout à suivre mais chacune
de ces activités leur sont simples dans
l'optique où il faut cumuler des points
c'est votre bracelet ces points ne sont
échangeables contre de la marchandise de
l'événement et puis pourquoi on faire ça
c'est qu'au final il faut démocratiser
l'hiver règle c'est ça le concept des
hivernales du 375e donc faire jouer les
gens dehors l'hiver c'est vraiment sans
être conscient qu'on ne peut réinventer
ses activités
ok le lancer du sapin c'est un peu drôle
mais on vous invite et ça s'appelle rené
voir tout un concept assez fly et il n'y
a pas si longtemps donc cet été on a
lancé l'événement jump up à travers
notre festival qui s'appelle jackalope
jackalope sur le plus gros festival de
sports extrêmes au canada qui se tient
au parc olympique première édition en
ce succès s'est rendu jusqu'à la
cinquième édition cette année
et cette année pour couronner la
cinquième édition des de décider de
challenge et un peu le stade
et puis on leur a dit pourquoi on ferait
pas sauter dégâts en parachute d'une
mode du stade olympique savoir une
compétition de base jump ce don qui sort
d'un objet parachute sort perdante mais
une cible au sol il faut qu'à tirer sur
le boulot est donc là ils ont vu que
maintenant quand la bombe a sauté en
parachute du mode stade mais on leur a
montré que c'est sécuritaire leur a
montré que ça paraît premire événements
ils nous ont vus grandir depuis le début
jusqu al
maintenant nous ont fait confiance a
super bien été je montre qu'un second de
teaser
[Musique]
de pareils l'événement est un énorme
succès généré des millions d'impressions
dans les médias de masse on a rejoint à
peu près je pense que c'est comme 40
millions d'impressions dans les médias
de masse bref cinq pages de couverture
partout imaginer les choux on voit des
gens qui ont sauté en parachute du mot
du stade durant les jeux olympiques de
rio cet été pendant le 40e des jeux
olympiques de montréal
il y avait un momentum assez intéressant
avant de ramener le nez prochaine aussi
justement
mais je parle un peu de tout ça parce
qu'encore une fois on n'a pas inventé le
sport on le traîne dans un contexte
était différent avec une icône ce qui
pourrait sauter d'une autre touriste qui
vont tellement cet événement-là pourrait
s'exporter pu faire une tournée à
travers différentes tours dans le monde
avec un produit télévisuel puis
éventuellement un événement rassembleur
la réponse est oui mais en bowling tout
a commencé avec une idée j'invite un peu
tout le monde avec une idée dans la tête
que ce soit un petit projet comme un
gros ne jamais lâcher prise parce que
des fois la vie nous propose des
embûches puis des fois nous propose des
bonnes surprises mais à date je pense
qu'à chaque fois qu'on a eu des embûches
avait toujours gros qui allait par la
suite
voici quelques images du festival en
question incluant le bes jobs
[Musique]
sur tweets ce sport c'est un événement
qui était gratuit pendant quatre ans la
transformer en événement habiller cette
année ç'a super bien fonctionné on le
ramène l'année prochaine puis ce qui est
intéressant c'est que on est
actuellement la seule étape au canada de
coupe du monde de skateboard la coupe du
monde de skateboard ça veut dire quoi
avant ça veut presque rien dire mais
avec les olympiques de 2020 montréal
pourrait être l'oeuvre l'événement de
qualification officielle pour les jeux
olympiques de 2020 pour tokyo c'est à
dire que si les athlètes canadiens en
skate ou dans l'escaladé je le faire
l'équipe canadienne
ils devront fort probable d'en passer
par jackalope au parc olympique dans
l'est de montréal bien sûr vous ça
générait beaucoup de couverture
médiatique
on a joué un peu avec la technologie
aussi à travers le temps la réalité
virtuelle je passais déjà vue
éventuellement c'est assez simple on
avait un partenaire avec telus et puis
aux redmen
et puis on leur demande et s'était
ouvert à faire quelque chose de
différent soit 2 quand les gens y
viennent au kiosque iron man pour telus
on leur montrait c'est quoi un
entraînement dans un raid mène à travers
des lunettes 3,60 donc
petits et grands sont venus au kiosque
de la marque durant l'événement et ont
pu vivre l'expérience en 360 degrés un
peu comme on peut le voir dans le dos
aujourd'hui immense succès on a même
gagné un prix infopresse avec eux et
puis je termine un peu en vous disant
que ça partager un peu mon ange
l'histoire aujourd'hui peu les soirs
pour me vanter mais simplement pour vous
dire que tout a commencé avec une
rencontre d'un événement de chambre de
commerce puis je tiens à les remercier
encore une fois parce que des fois on va
dans des endroits qu'on sait pas si ça
va être bon pour nous puis des fois ça
marche pas des fois ça marche
mais chose certaine il ya beaucoup de
gens qui croisent notre route à travers
à travers la vie et puis je pense que
c'est important de toujours être à
l'affût parce que plusieurs opportunités
à saisir et de la créativité à montréal
comme ça se peut pas montréal va
rayonner à l'international avec le 375e
vous avez suivi les élections
américaines
il ya toute une campagne de tourisme
montréal qui s'en vient qui va cibler
tout le nord-est des etats-unis qui va
leur dire on a un gros party qui s'en
vient mais vous à montréal venez voir
avec faut que montréal se mettre 60 36
le 375e s'en vient ça va brasser
on était heureux de lancer les
célébrations en janvier prochain il va
énormément de programmation comme je
disais nous notre but c'est de rejoindre
les jeunes les adultes qui ne
vieillissent pas ceux qui veulent rester
jeunes de coeur et puis je remercie pour
votre écoute vous avez été un public
remarquable n'hésitez pas à me voir
celui des questions par la syrie
[Applaudissements]